[Music]
you
um so hi everyone I'm Lucy thank you so
much for coming here it really means a
lot to me it's such an honor that you
all decide to come here while there are
some other really cool sessions going on
so I can only rationalize your choice
and coming here by my using the click
bait East title talk but there is and I
will say that it definitely over
promises what I am going to talk about
something that you will believe it's not
it's not mine showing at all
so I just wanna let you guys know when
you're signing yourselves up for at the
very beginning of this talk so that I'm
not completely underwhelming queue by
the end so I just to just give an
overview or I'm going to be doing for
the next 40 minutes I'm going to be
talking about my journey and like
implementing this new algorithm for this
headline optimizer we use at BuzzFeed
and it's going to be part meaning
tutorial part self reflection there's
gonna be some self-loathing in there as
well so hopefully you'll find something
you like so I guess we can get started
ok so that wasn't the only title I
generated from this talk this is
actually also a terrible title but like
it's still very vague like the last one
that you just saw but it hopefully is
like slightly more precise maybe a
little bit more descriptive and yeah so
I'm gonna be talking about how I opted
amaizing I'd line optimizer fair enough
alright so that was in the last title
slide there's another one um this one
also super vague but maybe slightly more
precise in in its description and so I'm
talking about the successes over trials
of building this optimizer so there's a
little asset istic spun in there for you
and I really hate the word optimizer
because it just like literally doesn't
mean anything but this is unfortunately
like the nickname that the service has
adopted for
so you know what is butts feed it were
giant media company we produce all
different types of content video content
written content image like you know just
a lot of different types of original
content and you know a major one of
those categories of content is reine
content and our written content spans a
whole wide range of categories and come
in a lot of different flavors and you
know you'll see things that are like
super light hearted really funny
articles to things that are like you
know like investigate investigative
journalism pieces or you'll have some
like you know long-form essays and you
know all these things have like at least
one thing in common which is that you
know when you see links for these posts
anywhere whether that's on Buffy comm or
on Facebook or on Twitter it usually is
presented as like a card with a with a
title or headline and then it'll be
accompanied with a with the thumbnail
image and that is all that's presented
you usually before you decide to click
on something before he started to click
on it and read it so you know this is an
example of what that presentation looks
like so of course this is super
important us first important for us at
bust me to think about because you know
we want we want to make sure that these
you know title thumbnail cards are you
know very attractive and then people
will click on them and you know this is
something that our writers are
constantly think about because our
writers constantly want to get a lot of
traffic to their content and our writers
like we've built for them a service it's
an internal service that we call flexpro
inside BuzzFeed and it's a service that
allows these writers to come up with
their own variants of a title and
variant of a hell of a thumbnail image
and this service will test out all these
different title variants and different
thumbnail image variants
and then basically just test them live
on our website on our own domain on
BuzzFeed con and you know it'll expose
these different variants to different
users who are on our website and then
it'll you know figure out which one is
the most popular one which ones get is
the most attractive one so you know in
this image there's an example of what
that those variants might look like well
three of I believe nine of them so you
know here's some shopping article all
about here you know 24 clever products
I'll make you say why don't you invent
that and there's a you know one another
variant of that title is 24 ridiculously
clever products you'd wish you'll wish
you invented yourself you know and then
there's one image once the male
possibility is someone like grabbing
their genes and then another one is
someone slicing a block of butter and
you know one of the guess the genes one
prevailed but you know that's just one
example and this test is run on every
single post that's written at BuzzFeed
um yeah and then so this image shows
what that would look like when it's
being tested live on our website so you
know if you're reading any BuzzFeed
article on our website there's like a
right side bar of all these other links
that you can click on to read other
content on our site and you know this
sidebar is yeah just a running feed of
other posts that you can read so you
know there's that there's that example
again the 24 clever products and then
that's one variant being exposed in that
sidebar for all right for a bucket of
our users and the way it works is you
know users who come to our site they're
randomly assigned to a bucket of which
is basically like an exposure bucket
like like they'll be randomly assigned
to see just one of the nine variants
they're being tested for that same post
and you know it's functions like an a/b
test basically like a mini AV test for
that post and it just it just tests like
which variant is getting most clicks
across all those exposure buckets and
eventually the one with the highest
number of well the largest CTR by some
tically significant margin is chosen as
the winner and that becomes the default
fixed headline and thumbnail image for
that post so here's some press about
flex Pro this is a service that's
existed for many years and a predated my
existence at BuzzFeed so you know Busbee
just talked to his proudly talk about
this service like I mentioned it just
takes a few different headline and
thumbnail image configuration is test
them in real time and spits out the
best-performing configuration and then
some of our staff is grown to really
like this service and they'll start
using this as like a synonym for
optimizing so there's this very crass
tweet that's someone tweeting it out
where you know flex probing something
optimizes you know anything in life so
okay
so let me just briefly describe how the
original flex Pro works it basically -
no I'm sure - no and surprise it
function like a multi-armed bandit
system where it tested all these
different variants of a post by you know
using explore exploit it'll just give
all of these variants equal exposures on
our website they'll each like a have an
equal number of users seeing that
variant and then you know it'll decide
which you know which ones have highest
CTR in the beginning which ones look
most promising and then start greedily
promoting that post more and more and
giving more exposure to the ones that
look promising earlier on so in that way
maximizes clicks in a pretty good way
make sure that it's you know under
exposing the ones that show less promise
in the beginning and over exposing the
ones that show more promise in the
beginning so it is a greedy algorithm
and eventually a winner is selected and
this is deemed by you know being that
having a high CTR by some significant
margin and that's that so you know it
seems totally fine like this is a great
algorithm why is there a problem here so
this has more to do with where a product
priorities are
so you know this algorithm is working
really well for optimize and clicks on
our website but that's only a small
sliver of the full picture of you know
what like of driving traffic to a post a
post you know as a dimension in our
keynote talk panel talk like no one goes
on like you know no one types in
BuzzFeed comm or people do but it's it's
not like it's not common like people
don't often type in bus be calm and just
browse our website looking for content
to read it usually shows up on Facebook
or Twitter
in your feeds and then that's why you
click on it or they because your friends
are sharing it so you know for that
reason you know it you know the biggest
part of this process of driving traffic
to a post is you know you test the
variants you find the winner
the winning thumbnail image and winning
thumbnail title and then you disseminate
that winner across social media and
that's the the major thing we want to
keep in mind so because that third step
is something that's very time-sensitive
we want to make sure we get our posts
out as fast as possible especially if
you know it's like a breaking news post
we want to make sure you know that that
is that it gets tested for the best
headline and image as fast as possible
so you know it's not our product focus
was no longer about like let's drive
maximum clicks on our website it was
about let's drive maximum clicks on
social media because most of our clicks
are starting to come from there anyways
so you know for that reason we had a
need for speed speed was a priority we
want to make sure these optimal headline
variants and image variants are getting
generated or getting resolved as much as
fast as possible and you know if we
don't get get it if we don't run the
posts to this optimizer fast enough or
if the I mean if the optimizer doesn't
resolve the test fast enough then we
have to end up disseminating the version
of the post that doesn't have the you
know the tried and tested headline and
thumbnail variant so you know we're
really like losing potential clicks if
we're disseminating the you know the non
optimized title and image so for this
reason we there is a you know there's a
school an opportunity
try out something new and you know one
reason we didn't just simply think like
why don't we just you know well let's
just tweak this multi-armed and at first
well the there's like an external there
are some external factors I play that
prevented us from being able to just
work with what we had already it was you
know something built many years ago it
was you know there's a lot of technical
debt involved in there it's dependent on
a lot of old legacy systems that we were
you know independently trying to
decommission so for this reason there
there wasn't need to either just get rid
of flexpro completely or just just
reanimate it in a different form and
completely from scratch so with this in
mind I decided to look at you know the
existing problems with the old algorithm
and see what potential solutions there
were for this I'm so like I mentioned
speed was a major thing and that was
something that I had to keep in mind
when developing this new version so what
was this algorithm um super easy to
implement decided to just maybe try this
first
so she says we do know how much time to
just like talk together something new um
so I decided maybe I'll give things
maybe testing a try as an alternative to
multi-armed bandit so you know the major
advantages that it has over this aside
from it just being like very easy to
implement is that it gives its any a be
testing framework would it gives maximum
exposure to every variant because you're
giving uniform even exposure to all of
them so you are maximizing how many
trials essentially each variant gets so
you can achieve statistical significance
pretty fast given that you're not like
choking out view impressions from you
know some variants from the very
beginning so in that way you're
minimizing the duration of the test as
well it's gonna perform much faster and
then I also really just like it's just
like a little added bonus but it gives
really nicely interpreted will results
like which is really great as like I was
like giving feedback to humans where you
know our staff writers and putting all
these
from variants they want to know what
kind of headline and image performs
really well so when they see this
feedback like you know this headline
performed the best you know based on
this probability no or this has you know
90% probability of being better than
these other variants he generated then
then like that's very easy to assess for
them and then learn from that so those
are just some one like the basic reasons
why I decided to just try this out um so
just in case anyone doesn't really like
no is not too familiar with how this
works basically for a Bayesian a/b
testing all you're really doing is you
know yeah this AV testing framework you
you know you collect click and
impression data from every variant that
you have as you're testing it live on
the website and then you just you just
estimate the CTR distribution for them
and their CTR distributions are
estimated based on data distribution
that you fit on the clicking impression
data so this is yes so basically that
beta distribution maps out to the
probability density distribution for the
CTR or each variant and then you just
calculate just now that you have these
probability distributions for the CTR
you just calculate the probability for
each variant that it's better than the
rest of the variance so for varying a
you just calculate the probability that
it's better than variance BCD etc and
then you use these probabilities to
calculate the expected loss for each for
choosing any one of the variants so you
calculate for vary a the expected loss
that you that you'll get for shoot from
choosing variant a over choosing BC D or
e so that loss will be really high a
variant a is if you're not confident
that very a it's gonna perform that much
better you know if you just don't have
that many trials or impressions so you
know this is just like a very also very
interpretable output that you get and
it's kind of like what's the possible
risk associated with choosing a period a
versus B versus C and then you just
don't decide on a winner until it's
expected loss falls below certain Creed
find threshold and and you know this is
also like a good way to just like make
sure you're not biased or you're not
like you know making any decisions too
early you just want to have a preset
threshold of caring as they call it
which is just how much loss to your CTR
are you willing to take so this is also
this is very basic I'm sure for a lot of
you but just to like capture the essence
of how this works what's nice about a
bayesian av-test approach is that it's
faster than using like a statistical
t-test approach to a be testing that's
because you know if you're plotting out
the CTR distributions for a blue variant
versus an orange variant like on the
left side you know when you have less
trials or less impressions they're gonna
be pretty wide distributions they're
gonna have a lot of overlap you know
that much confidence in them but and you
know in that case you can kind you like
it's pretty obvious or not obvious but
it's like it's pretty probable that
orange will outperform blue or is
outperforming blue but there's still
that overlap between the their
distributions that you don't want to
make that conclusion yet necessarily I
don't know so you know the principle is
that you know if you wait longer until
more impressions come in so you know
multiply that by 10 now on the right
side you'll see that orange is like
pretty definitively better than blue but
with Bayesian ami testing you don't
necessarily need to wait that long that
could take you know many hours in unreal
like website testing so we want to you
know in this kind of scenario where
there's already a certain high
confidence that orange is gonna
outperform blue and the left side of the
plot this early on the test like why not
just resolve it there so that's kind of
part of why it works so fast okay so
this is the self-loathing part I
promised I'm sure none of I'm sure very
few of you would ever make the Cystic
mistake I made but I decided like I saw
these like nice formulas for estimating
the CTR probability distributions I
thought oh this is so cool let me just
code this
so you know I was well first I was like
let me derive the probability that
variant a is better than Berrien be
alright a few hours past I'm like okay
so now I have to calculate the same
probability that variant a is better
than B and C and D and that was just a
nightmare and then once I did that I was
like okay let me try to code this and
that would just became completely
infeasible and so I gave up on that
because I should have just known at the
time that I could've just done some
Monte Carlo simulations so she was super
obvious for a lot of you but yeah so
this is just much easier way to approach
these districts you know looking at
these probability CTR distributions and
it really just reduced this function to
just three lines of code in Python so
this was like like oh this was amazing
so basically all you're doing is you
just like drawing samples from I hat you
have these CTR distributions fitted for
a variant a and then you have you have
one for a and then you have CTR
distribution for B and then you just
pull random samples from a distribution
and B's distribution and then the number
of times that a beats be in your random
draw you just average that across all
your iterations and that's just the
probability that a is better than B
which is so much more simplified and
then you just choose you know whatever
number of iterations that you want so
like I did like a thousand or 10,000 and
then that also simplifies multivariant
comparison to where you're calculating
probability that a is better than B and
C and B just super easy and then from
there it's also just super easy to
calculate the expected loss so like I
mentioned you're making any decision
that comes with a risk and in this I'd
like to think of this as like
calculating the worst case scenario of
choosing any variant as the winner so
you know when you choose variant a is
the winner yes it might have the best
CTR average CTR so far out of all the
variants the other variance for that
post but you know if you just
have that many trials by which I mean
impressions and your tests so far your
confidence not be that high so the
worst-case scenario could be pretty bad
and this is just a way to easily
calculate that what that worst-case
scenario is and it's super interprete
Balazs well the basic gist of this is
that you're also doing this Monte Carlo
simulation thing your brain only drawing
from every variants easier distribution
anytime the you know if your calculate
the expected loss of bringing hey any
time variant a CTR is the highest your
expected loss is zero you don't lose
anything anytime you know for any
iteration where variant a CTR is not the
highest you take the highest CTR from
the pool of variance and then you take
the difference between that one and very
an ace CTR and then that's the expected
loss you'll get in CTR for choosing a in
that round and then you just repeat this
for multiple rounds I mean you just
average the number you just average the
expected losses across all those
iterations and then that's that's just
your expected loss for choosing variant
a and I really like this because it
looks it is a CT like it is a real-life
interpret like intuitive value that you
get as output like so for example you
know if you if the expected loss of
variant a is you know point five percent
CTR that means you're you know
worst-case scenario for choosing variant
a is that you lose point five percent to
your CTR so for any product managers
this is like a really nice way to like
report to them hey if you want to set
this threshold of like what the expected
loss loss should fall under just tell me
what you think the worst CTR like the
worst drop in CTR we could possibly like
like we could possibly accept is and
then I'll just set that as the parameter
in the on very alone so I mentioned this
briefly before but yeah this is known as
a threshold of caring this is just the
like this is what you're like decision
threshold is this is just that you know
for any variant that you're choosing
it's the winner if not variants expected
loss falls below you know 0.5% CTR then
then you're good then we feel safe we
feel like we feel safe about this
decision we feel
we could take on this risk of choosing
variant a yeah so you know an example
values we know 1% point oh five percent
for the threshold of caring and if it
does not fall below if none of the
variants have an expected loss
calculation or falls below this is this
threshold of caring then just keep
testing keep collecting more clicks and
impressions and don't resolve the test
yet cool but then of course there are
scenarios where the you know the writer
generates some different variants of a
title or an image and they all are
almost indistinguishable they're all
very similar it's funny cuz some writers
will do this they'll just have two
different title variants with that are
off by like one preposition and then
they'll think that will make the
difference in in clicks but that's not
the case like from a lot of these times
so it is very common that we'll have all
these different variants being tested
and none of them are significantly
different from each other
so this would inevitably lead to an
inconclusive test and the way that we
would want to handle this is just you
know we don't want to waste anyone's
time by having people wait and wait and
wait like you know 12 hours until
eventually or the amount sometimes
they'll have to wait forever because
there really is no it's gonna be no
difference emerging so in those cases we
just want to impose a hard limit on on
how long this test can run or how so we
basically call this like an impression
limit so just you know once it exceeds a
certain number of impressions exposed to
every variant just cut it off just
resolve to something and that's easy if
they're all tied if every variant is the
same essentially in their CTRs and then
just randomly pick one of them or
defaults to like a pre-designated one
that that the writer doesn't need it as
like the one to default to if nothing
gets selected
okay so that's simple right well there
is also this other scenario that
Bayesian a/b testing cannot account for
so these are this is another tweak that
have to be added to the algorithm
basically what I the method I talked
about so far will just not resolve
everything that has a tie and it will
resolve if one of them clearly emerges
as like beat having a significantly
higher CTR than the others in this case
you know in this first line I have a B
and C a has definitively higher CTR
it'll probably get chosen as the winner
but what if there's only a clear loser
and no clear winner so in the case of a
B and C on the second line a and B are
tied for first place and C is clearly
something that should be weeded out of
the equation so in this case what the
algorithm did so far was just results in
nothing and I started realizing this
once was that once it was actually in
production that this was not cool
because C is something that needs to be
weeded out and sometimes C was the
pre-designated variant that a writer
chose so we don't want to make sure that
doesn't that never get selected so in
those situations I just like me I just
implemented this other requirement that
a or b like in this in cases like these
you just need to make sure that the
highest-performing variant is better
than the lowest-performing variant by
some ratio and then just choose among
the the ties the tied variants that are
tied for first place so that was pretty
straightforward eventually everything I
discussed so far can be just plot out to
this like pretty basic decision tree and
that's just what the algorithm look like
in the end and the other algorithm
itself I just discussed we're choosing
the winner only end up being like 20
lines it was very very tiny so this was
you know once I got over that like at my
life moment with like the closed form
probability formulas
everything was just like smooth sailing
very very easy coding wise it was just
like a piece of cake
so this reduced the resolve time from
like on average one day proposed to one
one and a half hours so this was really
good for our timeliness goal but of
course this raises a huge question right
if I'm going to reduce the testing time
by this much the confidence or the
actual like precision of the output must
be terrible right it must be like
there's this obvious obviously something
that I'm sacrificing here by reducing
this testing time there must be
something we're like completely losing
here so
your stuff was to evaluate the actual
effectiveness of this algorithm did my
change actually do anything
did it make everything worse which is
very very probable so you know the goal
for this whole evaluation process was to
try to understand you know for every
post that used flexpro this optimizer
did it perform better than post that
didn't use it and you know what was the
average impact of it using that so that
was like question 1 question 2 was a
little trickier it was what was it
impact like what was the impact of using
flex Pro the one that I created version
2 versus the original line the
multi-armed bandit system right and I
want to make sure that you know there
was some improvement in and how post
performed by using this version 2 in
comparison to version 1 so my hypothesis
was that you know version 2 hopefully
ideally would be which was a Bayesian
a/b testing version will perform best in
social platform traffic so the type of
traffic that was dependent on speed that
was dependent on getting these results
decided very fast that we could publish
this on on social media on Facebook and
Twitter and and there's it's failed at
that then I really like failed
everything and then version 1 which is a
multi-armed bandit version I hypothesize
will perform best in on-site views
because that's exactly the domain in
which it was optimizing for even though
it was taking such a long time so
unfortunately this was a scenario which
I couldn't use and actually beat a B
test which sounds weird because it's
very meta cuz like I'm a be testing an
a/b test service but it's fine
so the main reason was like you know
data science wise the main reason was
that you can't really publish a post
onto a social platform with two variants
of equal exposure with the perfectly
well controlled environment there was no
way to actually test that and then you
know another reason was that this was
kind of just like a reason out of my
control but even more so but it's just
version 1 and was like already dead
I couldn't couldn't just reanimate it at
that point to afford for comparing
against version two um so one night one
one approach one can take is just
bucketing all posts that use flex Pro
and then bucketing all posts that didn't
use flex bro conveniently only about 50%
of posts actually were run through flex
bro it's really up to the writer of that
post if their choice some just don't
trust flex Pro some trust it may be too
much so in that way we have like a nice
like one to one comparison of posts a
with Flex / on and post with Flex Pro
off one can see this as you know flex
Pro on posts or like your treatment
group and like a drug effect in this
study right it's they were treated with
lexapro and then you can group all of
the ones that didn't use flex Pro so the
Flex Pro off group as like your control
group right um so the result of this was
was just like amazing because flex / off
post averaged only 56 thousand views
proposed flex Pro on post averaged about
two hundred thirty one thousand so
obviously I had an impact of like five
fold on these posts right flex you know
the ones that use flex pay on we're
guaranteed to have five times the number
of views as one I didn't use flex Pro um
so you know this is demonstrated by this
pretty ugly bar graph that I made uh
where you know this towering the bar is
you know represents the average post
views or the total post views that a
post with Flex Pro on would have and
then compare that to this tiny little
bar which is how many views on post
without flex Pro so I guess that five
fold improvement this is amazing I was
like I've just completely excelled in
this but the problem was that obviously
this was not a causal approach and you
know at the keynote talk this morning
they talked at length about how like
causal methods and causal inference is
something that should be implemented
more often especially in my case
so you know the whole point of this is
that it's pretty obvious to see why post
that use flex bro could have such
different performance and post that
didn't use it and that's because it
usually varies by who wrote the post
there are some people like it's very
well-known at BuzzFeed like who are like
the hit generators who are the people
cranking out viral hits for our site
every day and they're really good at it
and so you know we wanted to make sure
that that bias that confounding was
accounted for and you know that also
varies by the post category if it's a
news post it's a vertical if it's a quiz
post you know a celebrity post that also
varies with you know the writer and the
writers choice to use flexpro so the
idea is just use propensity matching and
the idea is behind this is assemble like
a pseudo treatment group where these are
posts where these are posted useful X
Pro and a pseudo control group where
these are posts I didn't use flex bro
like I mentioned before in the naive
approach but the difference is that you
want to reassemble these groups so that
every treatment group post has a
corresponding control group counterpart
where both of them have almost as like
equal likelihood to use flexpro and
basically when you want to do once
you've assembled these pseudo tests and
control groups you want to measure what
was the average number of views for the
treatment group versus the control group
and that's like the average treatment
effect and yeah so like this is
basically like a drug effectiveness
study you want to make sure that
everyone in this drug study in the test
group and a control group are both
seeking both have like equal likelihood
of seeking that drug right that drug
treatment so you want to make sure that
posts in both groups both equally likely
to use flexpro and so you know very easy
way to do this I left out some other
features just to like keep this like a
little cleaner but you you know I used
offer and vertical I was like these
confounding features
the dependent variable was flexpro usage
which I call flexpro on and then the
output the class probability output that
you get from a logistic regression it's
basically the probability that flexpro
is being used given who the author of
that post was and what category that
post was and then you know you do this
for every treatment group member every
post use flexpro and you just make sure
it has a matching counterpart in the
control group that has equal or similar
propensity which is a probability score
from the logistic regression from here
it's super easy one way to just estimate
that treatment effect is that you fit a
linear regression model you estimate the
number of views as your output based on
what's per usage as your first feature
and then your confounding features which
are author vertical etc and then you
just try to get that estimated beta
coefficient for flexpro usage and you
just repeat this whole process on like
you know thousand bootstrap samples of
your data set so that you can get some
confidence intervals on your average
treatment effect and basically you can
get these humongous error bars which is
what I got and you know just to like
quickly go over this plot the x-axis is
a type of view that that post got like
average on average what like what type
of view that post got which was you know
site used like I mentioned you suppose
to be like on views supposed to be at
views social views or just any views
coming from a social platform and in the
total so you know if when I'm comparing
version to version 1 which are these
different colored bars very hard to tell
me which one is better but you can see
that the error bars are at least above 0
percent change in views so you know
where the y axis at the impact on post
they're all positive which is good
mostly and then you also see as like as
I hypothesize the Bayesian be testing
version did better for speed and for
social platform views so that green bars
a little bit higher than the pink bar
there and then for a multi-vehicle
multi-armed bandit version and it
performed better for site news which was
also expected where the pink bars
slightly high
than that orange bar sorry third for the
green bar so you know there was no
fivefold improvement but I will accept
one point three five times improvement
thank you so much thank you so just a
reminder that we have a survey at the
table so if you like the top please
place one of those green papers in the
basket if you just thought it okay then
a yellow one or if you disliked it a red
one questions yes thanks so I've I have
a couple but maybe you can just get to
one of them the multi-armed bandit that
you used I'm assuming was it that was
like an epsilon greedy type of approach
or did you do like a Thompson sample I
think it was Thompson sampling so okay
so I'm a little bit I'm just curious as
to how why the differences are so big
because it's I think it's like a made of
posterior mm-hmm kind of in the same way
as a vision a/b test yeah so do you like
so I guess a like do you have any
intuition as to why it was so different
yeah and then the the the other question
is um with this kind of Bayesian
approach I think there's it's kind of
like well-known that it's hard to come
up with like a sample size estimate
because there isn't really that analog
of flick power so I wonder if you guys
deal with that or if you get data so
quickly that you don't even care you
just you know you just start running it
because you know within hours your face
you know and then and then finally if
you ever considered doing like a
multinomial Dersch way kind of approach
instead of doing like many betas and if
you have any opinions on that mm-hm
so first question yeah so okay so just
to preface this that multi-armed bandit
was like coded so many years ago so I
couldn't even get like a glimpse into
like how exactly it worked but I think
it was Thompson sampling and I think the
you know I think for the time that was
like a pretty good solution we weren't
getting as much traffic we also weren't
yeah like I said we didn't care that
much about speed of performance I think
that was in the end yeah like I could
see a lot of ways in which it would
really I'll perform this Bayesian AV
testing approach but I think the fact
that we couldn't tune the parameters to
make it faster and to make it like
resolve the test much faster I think was
a huge limitation to it so yeah this
wasn't the fairest comparison of the two
but I think that was one thing that one
liked constraint to keep in mind to why
it underperformed
and then I guess to answer your second
question the sampling yeah we we get
traffic like very fast my website so you
know I did something like preliminary
analysis just to understand like what
that traffic distribution looks like and
it was just like it was a very safe bet
to you know just know that we'll get
like a thousand impressions in like less
than an hour so yeah so that was
something that I didn't keep in mind and
then your third question no I do not
look into that as a solution this was
just like a just like hack this together
a really fast kind of thing so
you can kind of do like can't you just
find the maximum of them because you
have but because that would that would
be the that that's the generalization of
the beta binomial
mm-hmm
okay
other questions
okay I'm coming so I'm curious do do
writers ever ask for introspection on
the results which is to say I imagine
that sometimes they're curious why a
particular variant wins over another
does that happen and what do you tend to
say to them yeah so that's also like
then half the purpose of the service is
just like as like a feedback loop for
the writers to just like extract River
insights they want for a minute so to
that end we built a slack bot for them
that just like automatically surfaces
all the results of every experiment so
they could read results for their own
their own posts as well as a results for
their co-workers posts so yeah they
definitely got a lot of value out of
that
hello
I had a question yeah so I was
interested like how the variants are
generated so are those generated from
the input of the writer or or those are
those like auto-generated from the
article itself sorry can you repeat that
how are the headlines like the variants
right you just talked about how are
those generated are those like input of
the writers or is it like auto-generated
from the text itself oh it's a good
question um it's written by the authors
basically they give like two or three
variants they think best of and the
flexpro you alerts which one is better
yeah yeah so that did yes they they
input it but they did inspire a fun pet
project of like auto-generating ideal
headlines based on which one's perform
better at something worked on for like a
hackneyed project ones but you know
needless to say it didn't beat you know
[Music]